Germany where a father is appealing to
authorities to relaunch the
investigation into his son's death
almost a year ago Marcus hempel died
following a fight involving four
refugees on this CCTV footage Marcus in
black and his friend are shown with the
group
it was later judged to have been
self-defense on the part of the migrants
but his father claims security camera
video she was a different scenario Peter
Oliver spoke to him Carson Hempel son
Marcus was killed last year here in
Wittenberg after an altercation with
migrants when he spoken out about his
grievances at demonstrations he found
himself labeled and Nazi Oh as I came
forward on stage I politely asked the
audience to show a little respect so I
could tell the story of my son right in
front of me there was a group of asylum
seekers with a coordinator who is
showing them how to hold poles to result
properly and what slogans to shout
imagine how I felt as a father when you
see Syrian asylum seekers who came from
the same country as the person who
killed my son and they called me a Nazi
it was insane they leave off government
money that comes from my taxes every
month to pay for people like that his
son is also being painted as a white
nationalist by some media outlets in
Germany people are labeled left or right
this is the biggest mistake there is the
overwhelming majority of people are
centrist and their political ideals
they're not members of any party all
they won is their voice to be heard
obviously it is our right to demonstrate
peacefully on the street I criticize
equally the people who do Hitler salads
or follow other insane agendas at public
events it simply doesn't belong here
Carson has big problems with the
discrepancies in the versions of events
prosecutors ultimately decided that the
Syrian man acted in self-defense
Uschi Stovall I believe the way the
story was presented was planned from the
beginning imagine that in a city with so
many tourists suddenly news comes out
that a young German has been killed by
four syrian asylum seekers
from my point of view they wanted to
keep it quite the insolent was caught in
quite explicit detail on CCTV and mr.
Hempel insists that this shows a
different scene than the one portrayed
in legal documents
Charlie MA here take a look here at this
point my son has already been knocked
out is that self defense is that self
defense the police talked about multiple
hits but the state prosecutor says there
was only a single hit it doesn't match
either the state prosecutors in Germany
can't count or they align and assuming
that they all have a higher education I
would say that they are lying on the
29th of September a memorial service
will be held to mark the one-year
anniversary the hempel family insists
that they have not received justice for
the killing of their son Peter Oliver
Artie Vinton Berg
you